every time i take a step towards kind of
a better ideal in this direction
i make significantly more money and so i
figured i'd share it with you
but uh recently i've been spending a lot
of time reading um and specifically
reading
from people who make a lot more money
than i do and
i think that i haven't had a good um
kind of a little bit more heady of a
podcast until
recently so i'm going to try and break
that streak today so
one of the hardest learn lessons that
i've i mean and i'm still actively
learning it but
every time i take a step towards kind of
a better ideal in this direction
i make significantly more money and so i
figured i'd share it with you
so um in some of my earlier podcasts i
talk a lot about focus
right about learning to say no and i
think that over the last
year and a half two years there have
been my
hardest learned lessons were where i
said yes to opportunities that were now
at a larger size than what i used to
learn to say no to
and so i've referenced the opportunities
that that come to us
as like the woman in the red dress if
you're familiar with the matrix is that
the thing is is that at every
opportunity level as you level up
the opportunities become sexier right
the woman in the red dress becomes
more attractive because you know in the
very beginning before you've made any
money
anything is attractive you say yes to
anything
but then as you acquire more and more
skills more and more opportunities open
up and better and better opportunities
open up which is why
you have to like relearn the same same
concept but at a different level
right um because at one point you don't
say
you you say yes to a 10 million
opportunity or one million dollar
opportunity everything's relative right
but at another level you have to learn
to say no to that if you were above that
at that certain time and i think i've
made that mistake
multiple times at different levels and
so i'm partially making this
you know video for me and so um there's
a book called the road less stupid
it's really really good i'd highly
recommend it especially if you're an
entrepreneur
and especially if you're prone to
getting excited about new ideas
constantly wanting to innovate
constantly wanting to tweak and change
things um
which is really really you know the
thing that excites us a lot and it's a
lot of times it's the
the key to to big breakthroughs that
being said one of the quotes i used to
quote a lot uh was from jeff bezos who
said
um basically business is different from
baseball in that
uh in business uh in baseball when you
swing for the fences the most you can
ever score
is four runs right but in business every
once in a while when you step up to the
plate
if you hit the ball hard enough you can
score a thousand runs and um
so big people who bet big win big but
they
bear the cost of experimentation right
and so um
the he references earlier on in that in
that little address that he said if you
have
a chance of a hundred times payoff and
you've got a
one out of ten chance of hitting it you
should take that bet every time
and after having thought about this i
mean jeff obviously makes a lot more
money than i do
um i think that that's not it's correct
mathematically but in practicality i
think there's another sentence that
needs to be added to it
and so to give it a realistic context
imagine
you're going to the casino and that's
the bet right that's the bet
is uh you have to put uh let's say
ten dollars down and you can win a
thousand but you've got a one out of ten
chance
right now here's where it makes it
realistic
let's say you only go into the casino
with thirty dollars
then what do you do think about it so
that means that if you were to bet three
times
you've got a one you've only you've only
got a one out of three chance of ever of
coming out of the casino with anything
right and so
that's i think a more realistic paradigm
for what most entrepreneurs go into is
because you have
a constrained amount of capital money
and a constraint amount of time
and resources and bandwidth for your
team and so
kind of adapting that extra sentence on
there of just understanding that there's
a cost to making that bet
it's not just oh if i have a one out of
10 chance of scoring a thousand
um then i should definitely make that
bet every time for a 10
bet yes you absolutely should
mathematically and
in jeff's case he's had access to
unlimited money
virtually unlimited money for 20 years
he's been able to re
raise funding um and fund i mean they
have 500 million dollar mess-ups and
they're like whoops that didn't work
but a lot of us don't have that and so
um
there's in the in the the book the road
less stupid he gives a context
um that i think has really really been
useful for me even lately
in making decisions about opportunities
right it's the things that i have to say
no to and so
the three questions are really simple
which is why i've been using them so
much which is
what's my upside what's my downside
and can i live assuming that the
downside is going to happen
and so the third question stated a
little bit differently but that's how
i'm using it
and in phrasing the three questions that
way
it's helped me so much in
saying no right in like man why don't we
try this new follow-up sequence so that
we can
get you know uh more leads in well
what's the what's my upside maybe i get
a 10
boost what's my downside i lose 50
because the test doesn't work or it
bombs because what i'm going against is
a control which has already been tested
against other things and is working and
can i live with my downside of losing
fifty percent
for the hopes of gaining ten no i can't
because i'm gonna assume i'm gonna make
that loss
and so then i just say no and what's
happening is it's giving me so much
attention back
so that when i'm making my bets because
ultimately if you really think about
what business is it at it's very basic
it's just betting which is why a lot of
entrepreneurs love gambling
uh because it's what we do we do it in a
controlled setting it's like
you know business is the ultimate
version of poker right like poker is a
combination of skill
and luck right business i would say is
even more skill
and still a little bit of luck and so it
just has more skill under control but
the other day there's still bets they're
replacing it's not just on black and
black and red it's should i hire a
salesperson first or should i spend more
in this marketing campaign
uh should i test out this new follow-up
sequence or should we try and run
seo uh or should we do cold outbound
messenger
right and so it's like all of these
things are decisions where you're
choosing between two different
opportunities
and i think if you apply that framework
that three question framework it's been
i just like
for me it's been a game changer it's
been so helpful um
and we've seen you know huge reaps you
know we've reaped the benefit in the
business
just in the last 90 days even during
covid we've had some explosive growth
i'll tell you more about it in a couple
months um
but it's been in really trying to hone
that discipline and i feel like at every
level
you get that that discipline muscle gets
stronger and stronger and stronger
and the things that i'm able to say no
to get better and better and better and
so um
one of the things that if you look at if
you study like charlie montgomery
they talk about the best the best
bettors the best gamblers
actually bet the the least frequently
they actually bet the fewest amount of
times
but when they met they bet big and so
um i'm trying to really apply that and
when they bet big
they bet on what they call no brainers
right it shouldn't be
like you should have in their mind it
virtually no chance of not succeeding
when you make the bet
right and then if you think about that
then you're like well shoot there's i
mean
when will i ever see those types of bets
if you look at them
over 40 years they only have 15 bets
that have created all of the the
billions that they've been able to
generate 15
15 winning bets out of all the bets
they've made have been the winning bets
that got them to where they are
and i think that in business it's a lot
like that so let me just tell you one
one quick anecdote to wrap this up
to make this real for you tell me if
this sounds realistic
you get really excited about a new
concept a new idea that you think you're
going to test out
right and you uh
you pitch it to the team you let them
know what's going to happen you're
saying we're starting on monday this
could be the new way we do things
the team's not 100 um trained up on it
but they're kind of go you know fly as
you go your
speed is king let's rock and roll with
this thing
and after a month or two months you look
back at your stats and
they're pretty much the same maybe even
a little bit less but there's like three
other things that happen during that
same period of time so like i don't know
if it was this or it was because of the
new process
honestly you know there's this and that
and then all of a sudden
you realize that you didn't even get a
definitive answer on the test that you
ran
um and you definitely didn't get the
result that you were hoping for
and so what ends up happening is that
your company and you
incurred this enormous cost of change
without
real like without any real upside and so
in in thinking through the bets that i'm
making now
i'm assuming the cost and what i mean
like i'm assuming
that i'm gonna have the downside even
the one that i'm understanding but i'm
assuming there's gonna be some that are
unknown that i'm going to have to incur
and so when i'm making that assumption
which is that third question which is
and can i live with it assuming that it
does happen
i ca it's just like it's been it's been
so illuminating for me and so helpful
for me because what happens is
you get in these vicious cycles
especially um
especially if you're in an emotional
situation right because i know a lot of
a lot of um where a lot of business
owners in general right now are cash
constrained they're trying to figure out
what to do they're trying to pivot fast
make fast decisions on on incomplete
information
sometimes that's just the name of the
game right
but in doing that um they're they're
hoping
for the hail mary and so their internal
optimism which is what leads them to be
an entrepreneur
ends up ends up weighing against them it
ends up stacking the chips
against them because that one thing
which has been your
your hope right your greatest strengths
can become your greatest weakness as an
entrepreneur there's no different right
our optimism can become our achilles
heel because we believe
that the chance of success is actually
greater than it really is
and we underestimate the cost of taking
the bet
and that's where we get [ __ ] right and
so when you go back to the casino
and when you're considering the bets and
you're like man if this hits
this could be ten times what we're doing
right now right
but just remember you only might have
three bets to make and you got a one out
of ten shot
so use them wisely so anyways i hope
that was useful for you it's been
incredibly useful for me
um i've been saying no to way more um
tests and tweaks and variations and and
and and
and just small things that would really
distract the team and just saying guys
we're just gonna keep
we're gonna keep focusing on executing
we're gonna keep focusing on doing
better at the fundamentals
and it continues to pay dividends
because the team doesn't have to be
scattered they just have to think how
can we get one percent better every day
rather than one percent better for two
weeks and then change everything and
then one percent better for two weeks
and then change everything right
um where they never actually get to get
that long-term compounding
uh improvement which is what ultimately
will separate you over time so
like i said hope that was valuable for
you it's been it's been a huge lesson
for me
and in studying some of the the greats
the all-time greats seeing how they make
decisions seeing where they place their
bets
um i wish i had learned it earlier um
but hopefully i can pass you know at
least that that nugget on too because
it's been really helpful for me so lots
of love keeping awesome hope you ever
made
saturday and um hopefully
a beautiful view here from the from bear
lake
and i'll catch you guys soon
[Music]